Recently had good results with latest MRI appears resection, margins are clean,
now a tumor reduced in size from 10 centimeters to 1.8 centimeters, this person had surgical
resection. Plus suspect lymph nodes are now are not visible on latest CT skin admittable on
the MRI, getting another MRI next week for additional detail based on radiologist recommendation.
It appears that the oncologist still recommends 4 to 6 sessions of port-based
full-fox or just 5FU. I understand this is too weak in cancer cells and to prevent
distant metastasis, yet this is also something that's going to weaken the immune system
and does not kill cancer stem cells. When I ask they say it's all about the immune system,
it's not all about the immune system. Thoughts on general on the chemo process,
I just don't want to take unnecessary risks, not sure what strategy is more risky either.
Okay, so my thoughts on doing chemo, if you had a debolking procedure where the cancer was encapsulated
and they're able to basically get the entire capsule, no need for a while if there's probably
circulated tumor cells elsewhere, that would not be a reason to do chemo. Like if you have circulated
tumor cells, there's no cancer, your PET scan is completely clean, should a person do chemo at that
point? Yeah, that's real questionable. In this case, you know that there's still some cancer that's
present. It's smaller. You know, it's still, there's still some there. I would be more apt to say,
okay, I've gone this far to do the resection, resection, you know, I would be maybe willing to start
to do the chemo process and see how you do. Remember, some people petty genetically other detox
application pathways in the health of their liver, they could just sail right through this and,
you know, they have been, those are the people that have fantastic results with the chemo and it
did its job because you were able to get it out of the body before it was able to damage any healthy
cells. How are you going to know that? Well, the only way that you're going to know that is
to do one session at a time. So, you know, of course, I would pray about it. Of course, I would,
you know, give as much consideration as possible, but I wouldn't, you know, completely rule it out.
So, my opinion, you're getting multiple people's opinion. My opinion, I wouldn't rule it out.
This could, you know, really put an end to the, your, your struggle that you had up to this point
by doing maybe only a couple of sessions. Um, maybe, maybe make a deal with the oncologist say,
hey, I'll be willing to agree session at a time here. How I, how I do with it. If I do well with
the first session, I'll move on to the second session. If you'll be willing to take another scan after
three sessions, something like that. I mean, that seems reasonable. Um, because honestly, if you said,
well, why are you recommending four to six sessions? Uh, the session, he's going to say, well,
that's the bottom line is because that's what is recommended by the pharmaceutical company.
They might say, well, that's what we've done. And we've had great results. If you, if you pushed that
and said, have you ever done three sessions? I mean, they wouldn't have an answer. Um, so, the truth is,
is that, you know, 90% of the people just do what they tell them to do. So they don't test.
There is no test whether only one session is good or two sessions are good or who's who came up
put the four to six sessions, the pharmaceutical company. So there's nothing wrong with giving
some pushback. You know, hey, I'm willing to use my brain here that yeah, some chemo could really
knock down what's left. But, you know, I'm, I'm the one that's in control of my body and I'll decide
I want to stop. But I would like objective testing. Are you willing to do another MRI or CT scan?
That's what I would say.